wow my stomach's gonna hate me later but
i don't care
i do what i want okay
[Music]
hi guys my name is matt i am a tasty
junior producer here in los angeles
california and today i'm going to be
comparing the homemade and store-bought
versions of one of my favorite foods
macaroni and cheese so i'm just going to
go prep my station and then we can get
down to business
box mac and cheese is arguably one of
the easiest things to make start to
finish it takes no more than 15 minutes
on the plus side you only need two extra
ingredients milk and butter on the
downside i honestly can't tell you what
kind of cheese this is the box says it's
original flavored i have no idea what
that means i tried googling it and found
nothing but it's cheap it's easy it's
delicious it's mac and cheese
ah
i actually haven't had it in a while
just as good as i remembered it's better
when you eat it like this when you put
it on the fork
it tastes like i thought it would which
is to say
like not much it's nostalgic it brings
you back it's honestly actually pretty
good
[Music]
this one pot recipe was developed by
matthew another one of our producers
here at tasty like the box mac and
cheese it's super straightforward and
you can make it all in one pot
because you cook it milk you don't need
to strain the macaroni making everything
creamier
by using real cheese you get that gooey
texture and authentic flavor if you
don't want to use cheddar go ahead and
substitute it with an equal amount of
whatever cheese you'd like
and that's it you got a homemade version
of box mac and cheese
[Music]
it definitely tastes like cheese
and like the other one is kind of like
milk and noodle definitely has a
creamier
consistency
it's actually nice tasting it's
side-by-side craft you can really tell
that the cheddar like elevates the
cheesy flavor the real cheddar
for this last mac and cheese i wanted to
do a real showstopper so we're going
with a six cheese to ensure things would
be rich and creamy i started with a
bechamel which is just a thick milky
white sauce that you see in a lot of
classic recipes it will get a little
clumpy at first that is fine it'll get
smoother and creamier as you keep adding
more
feel free to play around with what kind
and how many spices you'd like i went
for smoky with just a hint of spiciness
[Music]
i chose to use six cheeses for a blend
of sharp smoky and creamy flavors you
don't need to add six cheeses but why
not you get a more complex mix of
flavors just make sure you use three
cups total
be aware a lot of these cheeses did not
come pre-shredded so i had to do it by
hand which was a lot more work
[Music]
to make this recipe really decadent add
a nice topping of cheese and bread
crumbs and broil that it'll give another
layer of texture and flavor that you
don't get in the first two recipes
while it takes twice the amount of time
more ingredients and much more effort
this mac and cheese will really bring
the house down
[Music]
oh wow
this is amazing there's definitely like
a lot more
complexity oh and there's a kick it's
super cheesy it's got like this little
browned bread crummy bits that's like a
little salty in the best way i mean this
is this is amazing
my favorite definitely
is the fancy mac and cheese
i am going to have to go with
kraft mac and cheese i mean without a
doubt the fancy gourmet mac and cheese
is my pick i'm gonna have to go with the
final one i think i'm gonna have to go
with number two
i can't say i'm too surprised with the
mac and cheeses people pick while the
showstopper took the most time and
effort it amazed everyone that ate it
plus it's the most versatile there are
countless ways for you to customize the
flavors and textures to make it your own
that being said some people really like
the box mac and cheese if you want
something quick cheap and nostalgic go
for it if you want the simplicity and
efficiency of the box mac and cheese but
with more flavor and flexibility the one
pot is your version
at the end of the day mac and cheese is
great and you really can't go wrong with
any recipe and i've had it like 10 times
this week but i haven't eaten all day
and i'm hungry